hi I'm John KO I'm the chair of the
Institute for large-scale innovation
based in San Francisco we look at
innovation as a societal issue and our
principal activity is running a global
network of currently about 31 national
chief innovation officers and trying to
set some standards for innovation at a
national and societal also global level
so I just finished chairing the
organization revolution in session which
have a lot to do with innovation in the
European and Central Asian regions I
think the most important priority is
simply to be clear about what innovation
is and what one can expect from it
whether one is a corporate private
sector player or a public sector player
generally speaking I think there's a lot
of vagueness and machinist and kind of
emotion around the term innovation and
what we need is clarity and crispness
which ultimately will translate into
management best practices and metrics
and and so on I also think that in my
view innovation is always about purpose
i define innovation as creativity
applied to some purpose to realize value
and to help define a desired future so
what is that desired future for European
countries for Europe is a region for
Central Asia is kind of an open question
and what you believe the purpose will be
will drive the execution and then
finally I think there's a wide variety
of approaches to innovation execution I
don't think there's any one size fits
all there's no textbook there's no
three-ring binder there simply a lot of
knowledge currently and growing that
people who are running companies and
running governments need to study think
about an experiment with any interests
of creating a really effective
innovation agenda